[Music]
my name is Chris this is my wife Amanda
we live in Bloomington Indiana
my mom was a stay-at-home mom until my
sister and I were probably in junior
high high school so dad was the only one
who worked so he always instilled good
finances and good money keeping not
really growing up with a father I guess
you must have noticed as I got older I
was just easily influenced by the
lifestyle that was bringing the money
that we didn't have and the first time I
ever saw cash in my life was just $2,000
cash being laid down just for somebody
driving somebody around for the night in
LA I sold marijuana on the streets when
I was 13 it was actually a neighbor of
mine that got me into it for 25 years
from when I was 13 years old I hustled
on Street in 2002 I was declared the
second largest marijuana distributor in
Bloomington Indiana by local PD
I started meeting up with these other
guys and these guys were just doing so
many good things like they're always
happy and smiling they didn't have like
the background that I had so it was like
a whole different world and I was just
so drawn to them and you always hear
when you're growing up the good die
young
but man I've known some cats that are
good that have died young and I just
don't understand it
my best friend Richard I was a home
invasion three guys that went in the
house and told everybody get on the
ground and just started shooting people
Richard Kali around the shoulder and he
bled out on the way to wish her in
Indianapolis and uh I was riding around
mad I really wanted to get somebody and
I remember riding around in the car well
a hundred Lions roam on an ar-15 in
Mitrovica
[Music]
and I'm flipping through the radio and I
hear his voice but he's talking about
God and he's to my money and so I
continued every day I would be driving
around anyway I just be listening to
this Dave Ramsey guy he started talking
about things that was just really
starting to hit me like he would quote
Zig Ziglar changed Maxwell so I'd start
listening to them hear what those guys
had to say and you know Dave always
talked about integrity and hard work and
Here I am with ample opportunities that
I've had along the way to get away from
their lifestyle but I just never dated
him when I started listening to Dave and
Zig and John that's when I stumbled
across integrity and morality and hard
work and I'm just thinking wow all this
stuff have never heard of before and
Here I am I found out I was deep in
personal development so I just continued
that path and of course I had gotten out
of that life continuing just the
personal development aspect always
learning just constantly I'm always
looking for some new substance I don't
hear more you know and so started
working
I was on people's yards cleaning a brush
I was doing what I've been hearing on
the radio getting out and working you
know I'm gonna be riding around and just
trying to live off everybody else's work
because at the end of the day it's all
about what you do in this life you know
and I was still doing the whole personal
development and I was listening to him
that was the key back then I was
listening but I've never really enacted
the whole day I'm super bad he just came
home one day and was like hey we're
doing this we're selling your car no
we're not that was kind of before I
started actually hearing about when to
sell the car yeah yeah so at first he
was very skeptical when I took her to
the Dave Ramsey class okay financial
peace he I was it was during the class I
started learning more about the
principles and you hear about all these
things on the radio and you try to put
it together you will mess up quick if
you don't get it right we started going
to the class started learning about the
money thing together and started working
on our budget started putting those
dollars where they needed to go it's
amazing when you start handing when
God's money the
way how things can just line up
it took us 31 months to pay off 47,000
$990 and 23 cents I suggest anybody to
take a look at the program if they're
not already looked at it because it
changes your life we did it through me
staying home and having her and it
really if you stick to it I mean it's
hard it's not easy but if you stick with
it then it is possible
one thing I want people to know there
might be out there that come from the
type of background that I do there's
always hope
it is not too late people ways talk
about the love of the streets what
streets ain't got no love for you they
only take you away from people that
actually do love you all of you have
potential every one of us have potential
but the fact is as I took those first
steps and did it and that's all I'm
telling everybody out there is just do
those first steps get away from that
life
quit losing people there's babies either
growing up without families my homeboy
has a baby out there not without him I
don't ever want my daughter to see a
life without me as you want
[Music]
you